[Music]
so today I wanted to show you a game i
beat my favorite student my favorite
student is Matt Larsen now he is not in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame because
now the parents will get scared he's six
foot two a hundred and fifteen pounds
that bet back me up yeah it's true story
and he's my student he's 16 years old
and I've been teaching him for four
years three years when I started
teaching he was 1,100 rated that's
better than most of you and now he's 20
to 30 that's still better than most of
you and I only took him four years so if
your rating is a thousand you could be a
master in four years that you could
teach the class then you get Perrier
okay that's unfortunate okay so I played
Matt on Friday what's today Sunday
Sunday why do I know today is Sunday
oh yeah Super Bowl okay and I had the
black pieces
he played D for an unknown move no I'm
kidding and we did all this kind of
stuff
and I played this ship f5 which is very
unusual
so did he play e4 and then I had two
pieces that could take it and he had one
defending it so I must have won upon
then so guess what he didn't do that he
played Knight f3 and now he made a
really mean move he played Knight h4
that move doesn't smell very good
because it's nh4 like one of the three
of your parents got that okay then maybe
one kid got it maybe now you know take
chemistry yet
now nothing nh4 what's at age four well
in h3 and h4 ones ammonia ones ammonium
right okay so that didn't smell okay so
he attacked my bishop but I didn't see
it right now I saw now I made the worst
move ever here to keep him on his toes
he didn't expect that okay
I shouldn't play Bishop to d7 where it's
safe
Dustin Hoffman approved because it's
safe okay
and none of the kids got that maybe one
or two parent Marathon Man anybody in
the back know Dustin huh okay good
see somebody got it okay Bishop e6
attacking his pawn haha so he resigned
okay let's look at the next game now now
he made a move I didn't see because it
was too obvious I can't see the obvious
only complicated he played efore notice
how his bishop is protecting his pawn
also his pawns are pretty good all right
so I like to get my pieces out unlike
you guys but I couldn't figure out how
to get this Bishop out so I resigned
next game No so how do I get my bishop
out what did I do
I moved all these things out of the way
now g6 now a lot of you kids play g5
then they take your pawn and you lose
okay now he decided to castle and I
decided to castle so were the best hey
castle right and he played Bishop e3 all
right now in the King's Indian this
looks like a King's Indian black wants
to play e5 usually but I made sure I
couldn't do that because that made too
much sense yes Arjun it's like the
dragon because it's being played on a
chess board but that's about the only
similarity now okay so in the dragon
black fee and cattles is bishop right
yeah that's about it otherwise it's a
King's Indian although that's the Kings
Indian where blacks playing terribly
okay so if I can't play e5 I play d5
yeah I'm in the center do I get a prize
I did with a tournament ended but not
during the tournament he'd suck which
way did I take with a queen or the
bishop
bish that's terribly lose your Bishop
Queen takes X clam I mean Han Geng's
okay now he attacks my knight and I
played in the middle now in my opinion
which he doesn't agree with because he
didn't do it he should play f 4 and then
f 5 is the next move if possible then
the knight on h4 actually makes sense
but he took an I took okay now he made a
move that I quivered at yeah yeah he
played g4 not because he wanted to
checkmate me because his knights trapped
he can't go here can't go here can't go
here knight on the rim better for him
okay which you've never heard before
because I made it up after I stole it
from my friend but but the the correct
saying and the knight on the rim is dim
okay so he played g4 now his knight can
come back and he can fee and keto his
Knight okay so I played Knight to d7
because I want to play why play Knight
to d7 that doesn't make any sense
because then he would win a piece with
d5 so what did i do bishop d5 yeah
Bishop to d5 yay in the center he played
Knight G 297 now just like you guys we
both cancelled and got all of our minor
pieces out is that what you do
[Applause]
if you say no all the time you got to go
to the other class the 12 o'clock class
okay
he played Queen to d2 what's that call
what his Queen and Bishop are doing
what's that called bathrooms down the
hall Arjun yes it's a battery I
continued on with my with my stuff then
he played Bishop there and I moved my
queen here and he traded and played 93
it was a night f4 a z3 ok then we put
our rooks in the middle because that was
what we do
ok now he played on the side of the
board very suspicious Queen a5 why did
he play Queen a5 what's his next move
yes where are you saying no to all your
answers wait yes no he wouldn't do that
yeah you take my pawn and my nights
hanging I mean I thought I was going to
do that but he didn't so shows you what
I know
ok no that's what he's going to do he
wants to take this pawn so I play Bishop
to e6 because that unleashes this power
on d4 see also also I have a battery Rey
he played a bad move rook to d1 well he
doesn't think it's bad and I played
Knight d5 yeah ok now he made the worst
move ever and we had a lesson this
morning he's like this move isn't so bad
see usually you guys don't argue with me
but he argues with me every time that's
a bad move no it's not ok took my rib
with this Queen bad bat that's like
betting on Seattle huh
[Music]
alright who gets the prize for the
quietest it won't be the Broncos fans oh
okay so my opponent made a mistake he
thought I wanted to win his pawn well
he's right and the way I would do that
is I would take his a knight and then
his knight doesn't defend the pawn
because his Knights gone you see how
that works okay so if he was really
afraid of that he could play h3 or he
could ignore it and start doing what he
was trying to do in the first place with
Queen a5 but he didn't do any of that
he played g5 okay what would a car who
say terrible just terrible
okay who's a car ooh-hoo yes is about
that's who he is and what's his ranking
in the u.s. is he better than you yeah
what's his US ranking first he's the
best player in the US and he was number
three in the world last month not
anymore
so whose turn is it I white so g5 and
then I took this Knight and he played
the best to move he took back right
whoa f3 terrible like that okay now the
reason I took his Knight is his night
was defending a very important square
that I wanted to go to so I went to it
and I think that's called a fork I
attack his Bishop and his B pawn now I
want to show you a funny variation that
didn't happen okay uh yeah so I wanted
let's see he moves his Bishop here
attacking my queen and then let's say he
moves his Queen here to put pressure on
my rook I was going to play the craziest
move you ever saw Bishop to b3 that's
the best move yeah I wouldn't lie to you
not on purpose
okay and the reason is I'm getting my
bishop out of the way I want to play
queen g4 check which would lead to
checkmate but
that's illegal so Bishop b3 and then
queen g4 check now we're talking
right and then check me hurry for me
okay but that didn't happen okay so he
played wrote to d2 the worst move ever
but but he saved everything remember I
was forking the ship and pawn well he
saved it okay so he was hoping for rook
takes rook Queen takes rook that's fair
okay and I did something called removing
the defender how did the defender off
the board
he's like what are you doing how did I
remove the defender of his rook what's
defending his rook I just showed you
what is defending his rod how did I
remove the defender and when I made this
through he was not happy who's happy all
the time today's like oh yes who are you
sure correct
how does he move his Queen and stay on
the defense of his rook Queen c3 I'll
take that
who is incorrect but I'll call you
anyway never mind is correct yes Queen
it before he didn't play Queen before
because he knew if he did I would play a
five and remove the defender again
because that's what I do I remove the
defender now there's nothing he can do
except cry so so he took my rock I took
his queen he played this for some reason
I play here and then he gave up and then
we had a lesson two days later so now
Matt Larsen he was 1,100 now he's 2,200
if he does it again then I'll get
lessons from him he has to double it
again right then he'll be rated 4400
I'll still beat them because you know I
cook psychological edge
now how many players are playing in
Zurich right now six you guys remember
and I've played for rated games against
those six players I have in my life and
what's my score 100 out of four that's
good score two out of four would be good
because they're the best players in the
world seems unlikely right zero seems
likely the correct answer is three okay
but like I said that they wanted to
invite me to the tournament and they
offered all-you-can-eat Chinese I said
Indian we couldn't come to an agreement
so I'm teaching here instead okay and I
offered him Thai - and they're like now
in this position yeah but my queen is
better than his rook so yeah but I have
a queen and I have a queen yeah see I
have a queen and he has a rook for my
queen advantage me yeah same number of
pieces my pieces are worth more yeah so
that was a game I won on Friday and then
I got two wins and a draw so how many
points did I get three yeah two and a
half out of three sighs first place so I
won one of each bill 120 110 one five
and one one how much money is that the
good math skills yes
20:21 you making the cameraman laughs
over here is a professional trained
trained professional terrible all right
all right quiet please
we're going to look at my favorite game
from last year starring Peter O'Toole
boy that was my favorite year never mind
okay what's this opening called for a
prize come on wave it in front of you
what do this empty wrapper I this on
eBay it's worth like half a cent what's
this called
yes Rai Lopez that's an opening but not
this one
yes those are also openings okay this is
called the nimzo-indian named after your
favorite grandmaster aron nimzowitsch
well he is now and he was alive in the
1910s and 20s and 30s and he wrote a
book called my system he was like this
is how you should play chess I read it
once that I had a good nap okay so I
played here and he attacks my pawn but I
saw it okay we played Barney chess I
take you you take me he's the worst
player in history now hey they last more
than the younger kids that's good yeah
hi all right simmer simmer simmer turn
the heat down okay
now watch this see how I pin is night so
I pinned his knight did I do that
now now black can went upon for free
it's really hard to figure out but this
is the really hard class black to play
and went upon it's a three move
combination well it's a one move
combination three times so watch this
Bishop takes pawn Shack Knight g4 check
and then he takes the bishop is that
what I did yeah frankly ridiculous so I
play Knight f3 and now if he does the
same thing they stop that if he does the
same thing now my bishops protected by
my knight so he can't do that okay so he
unpinned and I got my Bishop out where
did I move my bishop right so I played
here he attacked my best shot but I saw
it and now where'd he move his bishop
now see played here and now just like
all of you guys we have all of our minor
pieces out and we castled
just like you do now this guy's even
higher rated than I am so he could teach
this class although it might be in
Spanish but you know how if you speak
Spanish okay so he's from your favorite
country 90 miles from Key West
incorrect Spain 90 miles from Key West
yes see the quietest person had the
right answer Cuba okay Cuba has a lot of
good chess players okay they're a small
island country they have like 15 grand
masters okay so I put my rook on some
kind of file
what's that file called open or half
open yeah and he did and he played here
then he put his rook on an open file
okay then I had all my works on his pawn
so I was going to play Knight here and
take his pawn and then he would cry okay
so he played a6 and then I decided that
would be a mistake now who's heard of
overworked and or overloaded game in at
the Chess Club here some of us are
overworked and during the Super Bowl
overloaded okay but that's that's during
that Super Bowl
okay so this Bishop here is overworked
look what it's doing it's defending all
these guys right so I took this guy and
if he takes back then I went a free pawn
hooray so he didn't do that he took this
way and now is this King safe
is it safe will they sue me no people
who maybe Bharath on me I won't sue me
is it safe yeah is it safe okay next
time you go to the dentist to ask if
it's safe
yeah now I played 94 why did I do that
why
who is incorrect it's still incorrect
yes on this bishop well I'm attacking
this pawn with lots of guys so he played
9b for attacking my queen and discover
attack on my knight you guys got to be
quiet cuz the camera and you know world
peace and stuff okay so did I save my
knight or my queen but if I move my
queen he'll take Y night so I had to
save my knight with this move then he
took my night because my Queens
overworked then he took my pawn and now
he's a pawn ahead so I gave up now is
that the best Square for your night that
nights that nights so bad you're not
envious of it it's red with
embarrassment oh man they laugh at
everything I got to bring you guys to my
comedy club you laugh at everything okay
so now I played 9 to d4 and he was
afraid I was going to play knight c6 for
King his Queen and Bishop so he made the
losing move it's good when the losing
move happens as long as you're playing
that person then you're not making the
losing move he played nine to be four
cuz his Knights not good there and he
defended that square what a good player
but I had a second threat he did not see
question
a 1 then he would play night before and
he defends his a6 pawn are you shocked
I'm a little shocked okay so we had a
great question he wanted to play for a
skewer but I'm a vegetarian
so I can't have a skewer less it's all
veggies that doesn't taste good what who
said that that's that's the first right
thing you said this class good job
what ok so this is a skewer which I
don't do okay because then how come I'll
come everything's like you're eating a
skewer a fork come on
ok so he'll play this fricassee move now
he defends his pawn so I can't take it
ok so I played 94 quiet please
now I set all my pieces so I could win
brilliantly everybody would clap I was
like who I keep this class in a few
months
exactly even before I did it class
dismissed
alright now watch this overworked pawn
that you didn't think was overworked
this pawn on f7 he's defending this pawn
you agree and he's defending Queen g6
check which would be really good for
white if he couldn't take it but he can
take it
so I played Knight takes c6 forking his
Queen and ruck what did he do he took
then I give him a check and he played
the same move you would have played here
and then we did a little dance well he's
from QB dance as well then I could play
Queen here that's called perpetual check
and that would be a draw did I want to
draw I think not
so I played Bishop to g4 because I want
all of my pieces to attack now if I take
that I'll wind like he plays this silly
move and I take that I'm threatening
checkmate and I'm threading his rook and
also you can't stop checkmate okay so
what should he do to save his pawn on e6
defended that's what he did
he could play f5 but then I would go
check check and then take this and then
I have 800 extra pawns plus I'm
threatening me and I'm threatening his
rook so he didn't like that so he played
Queen d7 is recommended
now I played a move so good this class
will be changed to intermediate plus I
played Bishop f5 threatening checkmate
then I would win so he played he he took
now I played rook here threatening
checkmate I could have done that earlier
but then this pawn would have moved out
of the way
and he would defend now his pawn can
move out of the way because I sacrificed
my bishop in front of it so how did he
stop rut gates for checkmate you got to
stop check later you lose now his rating
is 2700 so you knew how to stop
checkmate yes he did do a pawn now for
then I took it then he stopped checkmate
again with pawn to f5 and then I played
here because I really want to check meet
him now how did he defend this square
again he used his Queen right Queen to
d8 now I'll show you what he should have
done which I told him after the game I'm
like dude okay
that's when Ronan doesn't lecture dude
rook c7 is what he should have done then
Shaq takes takes here takes takes that's
why rook c7 now Queen takes d6 Forks the
rook and the night with some strange
arrows okay
and then he would lose which one the
night so you defend his rook maybe I
don't know now who do you think's
winning here yeah White has a thousand
extra pawns I don't count so well okay
so instead of doing that and losing that
way he lost a much nicer way he played
Queen to d8 notice how this doesn't work
anymore because I lose all my pieces so
I did do that however if I put my rook
anywhere else
it still checkmate so I played rook f3
because then rook at h3 would be leading
to checkmate
hooray so he blocked my rook by playing
f4 and now if I play rook check he can
just block now I play the move so good
it's intermediate plus plus okay plus
tax and I can't I can't teach this class
at Michigan because KX is too low
Missouri is just right but nine point
five or seven 9.10 it's ten something
ten oh then I can show this is pretty
high tax okay this is the most
overworked of all time you'll never see
more overworked okay the Queen and
Bishop are protecting h4 so I can't made
them and the Queen and Bishop are
protecting the d6 pawn so I can't take
it or can I so I took the d6 fun BAM
okay that's emeralds favorite move you
know BAM nothing okay so if he takes my
rook then checkmate gives white the
advantage notice how he can't block the
meet anymore and also I'm going to take
his Queen so he blocked in me and I had
a choice take his Queen or meet him me
that would be better now I have maiden
five but I have a good excuse I didn't
see it
and I didn't seed queen g6 track which
is pretty strong
then it's mate next to move instead I
made him in a much meaner way because I
didn't see the the mate and five do I
have all my pieces attacking and he has
a lot of pawns in front of his king here
here what do you think black did here
also incorrect I don't like to waste
time wait for you to answer
yes is that what he did didn't I already
say incorrect weren't you listening yes
didn't I already say incorrect King f7
is illegal yes correct
he gave up but the only legal move is
this and then this is really annoying
because he has to go here and then I
made him also annoying is Queen b6
and me or I could try to do it all right
so he didn't like any of that so he gave
up did I use all my pieces to attack or
just one and hit and he had good defense
of his king right what about my King
does my king safe okay
ah it's back rank checkmate except he's
always in check ah otherwise double
check me this looks like a bog house
scheme right okay and what University in
Saint Louis does he go to if he's good
at chess Webster which is in what city
Webster Groves own County
that's a city alright now don't forget
about Denver unless you don't forget
about Seattle one of them who gets the
prize for eating the most pizza tonight
how many more pizza than all you put
together you guys are you guys are like
rated 800 eating pizza 2,700 okay class
dismissed
bang
[Music]